[Music]
at long last the black widow solo movie
has arrived and natasha romanov is
getting her time in the spotlight
in addition to potentially laying the
groundwork for future stories
the prequel also offers a few sly winks
at the mcu
and marvel comics here are some easter
eggs you missed in black widow
when black widow moves to its present
day timeline of 2016
our title hero is on the run from
probably the busiest
secretary of state in us history retired
general thaddeus thunderbolt ross who's
convinced he's got her pinned
down natasha calls ross on his cell
warning him not to embarrass himself
it turns out that she's on a ferry in
norway which at best puts ross
six time zones and a continent away as
nat
settles into her new home courtesy of
her ally and supplier mason
she cracks a norwegian beer and settles
in to watch roger moore do his thing as
agent 07.
apparently she's a big enough james bond
fan to quote the film
line by line this easter egg comes in
the form of her movie of choice which
bond super fans will instantly recognize
as
moonraker there are some obvious
parallels between moonraker and black
widow both films feature an evil
megalomaniac bent on world domination
pulling strings from a remote base in
the sky a space station for moonraker
antagonist hugo drex and the hovering
red room installation of black widow big
bad
dracov both primary antagonists also
have a strong
and silent heavy drax chief henchman
jaws and dracov's daughter turned puppet
antonia
aka taskmaster who only speaks once
after their loyalty shifts
when his sleeper cell slash family
escapes the united states to cuba
alexi is thrilled after all he was the
red guardian the soviet union's first
and only super soldier
he had no business flying under the
radar in the american midwest stealing
secrets
he belongs on the battlefront
when natasha and elena rescue him from
prison he describes their time as a faux
family as
tedious and boring for which he tells an
obviously upset
elena he means no offense into writing
the only family she had ever known
as the movie goes on alexi's affections
for his fake daughters come out from
behind the gruff and rigid exterior he
shows the world
but viewers paying close attention to
his tattoos could have reached that
conclusion much
sooner those two roses on his bicep one
of which appears to have a drop of blood
or tear falling from it
it just so happens that the names on the
ribbon translate to natasha
and elena as natasha and elena are
flying in to free alexi
their tablet showing the facility's
layout gives away his location
seventh circle prison fans of certain
marvel comics properties will know that
there is an eight issue run of the
daredevil
punisher team up series called seventh
circle but even though the black widow
has been associated with both of those
characters previously
it's unlikely that's the intended
reference it seems much more likely that
it's a reference to dante's divine
comedy more specifically inferno and
dante's 14th century poem
the seventh circle of hell is where
sinners who've committed violence are
tortured by centaurs and harpies
fans of classical greek mythology may
recall harpies
loathsome screeching creatures with the
head of a woman and the body of a great
bird harassed aeneas in virgil's epic
poem the aeneid
spoiling his crew's food so they could
not eat
that sure sounds like a certain pair of
prison guards who've stolen the baked
goods alexis fans have sent
him before his liberation from the
seventh circle prison alexi regales his
fellow inmates with the tales of his
glory days as the red guardian
marvel comics soviet russian foil to
captain america
as he nonchalantly takes on all comers
in arm wrestling
it's clearly a tale they've heard before
but one prisoner credited as muscular
gulag
inmate to avoid spoilers doesn't buy
alexi's story
pointing out that captain america was
still frozen when the story supposedly
took place
alexi isn't amused asking are you
calling me a liar ursa before slamming
the man's arm to the table breaking it
look at the big bear he says mockingly
it looks like we just met mikhail
ursus aka ursa major a soviet mutant who
is able to transform into a brown bear
it's not the last time alexi's heyday is
mocked
at molina's farm he tries to comfort
elena only to have his concern
rebuffed she says the only thing you
care about is your stupid glory days as
the crimson dynamo and no one wants to
hear about it
it appears to be meant as an insult with
yelena either mocking his former code
name or
actually forgetting it which alexi
corrects but elena has actually invoked
yet another russian marvel character one
we're
unlikely to see in the mcu in a version
faithful to the source material
why crimson dynamo was the name anton
vonko
father to iron man 2 villain ivan vonko
aka whiplash
took when wearing his own powered armor
as elena and natasha are holed up in the
rafters of a hungarian subway station
the two discussed the latter's previous
time hiding out in budapest nats already
made a reference to clint barton aka
hawkeye
and telling elena that the holes in the
safehouse walls were made by arrows not
bullets
she then reveals that she and barton
spent two days hiding out there
previously
at which point the camera shows a series
of games played on a ventilation duct
there are a few games of tic-tac-toe
into game of hangman
which someone seems to have lost it
seems to pretty clearly spell
butterfly but it wouldn't make for much
of an easter egg if it was that
straightforward
these insects have been cropping up in
the mcu with the butterflies in wand
division being the most recent example
perhaps the most direct connection
is to layla miller aka butterfly a
marvel comics mutant with a broad range
of abilities
one of her powers is the ability to
reanimate living things
but without restoring their souls it's
an intriguing reference given the
exchange on vormir in endgame in which
natasha traded her life to get clint the
soul stone
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
black widow are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one